hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled development of luminex
based serological test for covid19
diagnosis and monitoring
this webinar is part of an ongoing
coronavirus virtual webinar
series i'm susie valdez of labyrinths
and i'll be our moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by a
roots and sponsored by luminex for more
information
about luminex go to luminexcorp.com
so let's get started i want to remind
one that this event is interactive
department by submitting as many
questions as you'd like during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
box
ask a question box and click send we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
simply click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education
credits click on the continuing
education credits tab
located at the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process
to obtain those credits without further
ado i now present today's
speaker dr emman tahroni a post-doctoral
fellow
at rush university medical center at
chicago
for a complete biography of our speaker
please visit our biography tab
at the top of your screen dr tahoni
you may now begin your presentation
welcome sir
hello susie hello everyone uh good
morning
i would like to thank you for this nice
introduction and uh
i would like also to thank everyone that
is attending the seminar today
uh today's presentation in today's
presentation i would like to
talk about our uh novel uh covet test
the novel test for covet 19 diagnosis
and monitoring
that we have been developing since the
beginning of this
pandemics uh before i begin i would like
to
introduce my team so beside me
christina dr jeffrey borgia and david
have been working tirelessly side by
side to develop
optimize and validate this test
and uh just one thing to mention here
um because the patent of this test is
is pending i'm a little bit limited
on the amount of data they can share
in terms of test specifics but i would
be happy to share
uh the validation results and uh
clinical results
so the layout of this talk will be uh
started with uh will be we'll begin with
uh
brief focused introduction on the covet
19 then i will describe
the current strategies and testing
methods for for the
coveted 19 followed by
a description of the basics and the
rational for
our tests and then the validation
results
finally i would be happy to take uh
your questions and answer them
after i uh talk a little bit about the
future directives
and so let's begin
so coronaviruses have been known
historically for being responsible for
a couple of major pandemics on the world
uh including
the sars in 2002 and uh
the mars 2012 this one
is considered to be a third hit by this
fellow creature in late
uh 2019 basically in december
coronavirus
uh uh have been identified by to be
responsible uh for a cluster of deadly
uh respiratory distress syndromes in
wuhan china
it rapidly spread resulting on
resulting in local epidemics and
followed by global pandemics which was
announced by who in mid
march in february 2020
who designated the covet 19 for the
disease
for that disease and designated the
the term sars cov2 for the virus but for
the convenience of this talk
i would be referring to this is uh
as to the covenant inside as a disease
and for the sars of two as virus
so let's take a closer look on the
coronavirus
coronaviruses are called uh corona
viruses
they are giving this name because of the
shape of their
of the ship that they take because of
those uh
spikes on their surface these spikes
that are
colored grid here they are colored red
for illustration but they are formed
of a form of glycoproteins that are
that is responsible for binding to the
angiotensin converting enzyme to
receptor on the
respiratory epithelial cells and they
facilitate the invasion
of the of the virus when we look at the
deeper structure of this
virus there beside the spike proteins
there are
the envelope proteins which work with uh
with the membrane protein to give that
spheroidal shape uh of the virus and uh
uh form the the viral envelope all that
encloses the the the nucleocapsid
protein
uh which also interacts with the
genetic the genetic component the gene
of the rna
the gene of the virus which is the rna
to form the nuclear capsule
i would come back to this structure
because it's essential for the
composition of our
assay so we'll go in detail into details
later
when we look at the pandemics figures
this slide by the way was created
in june 13th
so far the virus has infected
more than eight millions globally and it
caused uh i think
it took the life of more than 444
thousand all over the world fortunately
half of this number of this
half of these cases have already
recovered
in the u.s itself there is a fourth
of this number in terms of cases and the
fourth of this number enters
in terms of uh deaths the recovery is
still low
uh which is about 25 percent
so when we look in the on more details
the us is still leading the
the the the figures of the pandemics
in terms of deaths and uh and a number
of cases so when you look at the death
uh and the kiss fatality ratio u.s is
still
on on the forefront of this pandemic
brazil is climbing up
now um in the u.s we average
the average number of cases detected
daily
is 22 000 per day
uh 66 of them are among those age group
between average between 18 to 64.
um i would also come back to this uh
age group because it's it's essential
for designing the
the the the mass
screening strategy for the coven 19.
but the reason why these numbers are
high
uh in the u.s could be according to cdc
could be due to
the high testing capacity the united
states is trying to implement
so so far the u in the u.s we have been
conducting we have conducted
more than 23 million tests that can be
averaged to
half a million tests per day since the
beginning of march
with the positive rates of uh 11
so when the the interesting thing is
that
how the trend is different among
different
uh regions of the world and even as well
as
within the united states so if you look
at the graph on the left
the us seems to be
past the the peak of this hopefully
past the peak of this pandemic and uh
now it's still uh showing a fluctuation
of number of cases
uh when brazil like it's
just started to climb up the the curve
of the
of the of the cases when you look at the
right figure where we show different
states
it is not the same for for all the
states here in the u.s
so as some areas are prepared are
already recovered like
new york or new jersey
there are some other states which are
climbing just started to climb up like
arizona and arkansas and uh and
michigan as well so we see like some
regions are
started to plan for reopening and ease
the restrictions and some reasons
our regions are are just started to
to to to to climb up the peak
of the of the cases that could be
associated
with uh with the nature of the isn't
a symptomatic nature of the of some of
these cases
as we know that from five percent to
eighty percent of the people tested
positive
of uh of the virus have been
they they showed no symptoms or like my
myosin
symptoms in the past therefore a
large-scale
large-scale community level testing is
critical to control the disease and
reopen safely
so far since the beginning of the
pandemics nucleic acid
detection based on pcr has been the
major laboratory
test for diagnosis but
uh we have to mention that it's very
specific
but not uh as good as uh
we expect for in terms of sensitivity
it's very specific
specific because it's uh it detects
the viral gene sequence the rna sequence
that is specifically unique to this
virus
but there are a lot of technical issues
that we'll describe in next two slides
regarding the the sensitivity of the
that caused the low sensitivity of the
of the test for that reason
fda announced the emergency uh use or
authorization uh guide
to uh in in 2000 in uh sorry in february
2002
describing the policy regarding the
immediate use of tests developed by
certain certified laboratories
the objective of this guide is to
increase the testing capacity in the
united
states so what are the current
testing methods for the coven 19 so
beside the
the the pcr the reverse transcription
quantitative pcr
which is depending on the detection of a
nucleic acid
uh in the swab from the nasopharyngeal
uh or oropharyngeal swab
uh we have other tests like uh
detecting the viral antigen uh in the
same
sample uh as far as i know there is only
one
test that is uh that is approved by fda
and for which we don't know that much
information
in terms of validation the current
currently the
very common is that used uh in large
scale is the serological immunoassays
these immunoassays or psychological
tests are
planned to detect the immunized
patients or patients who developed
immunity to the disease to
uh to the virus basically they measure
the immunoglobulin mng
so they nowadays they are widely used in
layout
of the pcr
the rational for that is that pcr has a
couple of
limitations so pcr requires
high quality nasopharyngeal swab
containing it should contain a
sufficient amount of viral rna
to do this you that you have to
successfully follow specific techniques
that is
require certain training by operators
and
requires successful transport of media
and extraction steps
and in addition to that
the amount of viral rna may be may vary
from within the same patient and uh
according to the different times when
you take the test
and and also
this procedure can be unpleased to the
patient and
sampling techniques can depending on the
operator as i mentioned
all these factors can lead eventually to
insufficient
amount of viral rna that lead
to a false negative result
in addition to that as i mentioned the
this procedure require high
trained personnel to uh to from the
step of acquiring the sample to the step
of producing the results
for that uh this can be done in
in lower like in daily routines for for
hundreds of
cases but when we talk about large uh
groups in the pandemics that mean you're
trying to test
thousands of cases per day it's going to
be overwhelming to the
medical facilities and there will be a
huge backlog
of tests and results that the turnaround
will be
uh very high i assume
so the rationale for using the the
the immune say tests and layer of of
pcr in terms of screening is is this is
it
can be described in this slide and this
figure so if we look at the
at the beginning of this uh uh
graph in day zero that's that's
that indicates the the onset of symptoms
if if you look at the evidence of the
virus
you will see the virus on the on the
samples
so either the viral rna or the antigen
they will be high in the and uh
and thus by specimens either uh
the the nasopharyngeal swap or the urine
or the blood
they will be high um but that will go
down by the time
and according to average of the
time that was uh reported it goes down
by the day six and these numbers are
just averages
in terms of immunity
we see the immunoglobulin m that's uh
that's the red line and the
immunoglobulin g
they both go start going up
responding in average of three to four
days
so what i'm trying to say here is that
if you test
for the rna and the first three to four
days of the onset of symptoms you will
you'll see high sensitivity of the test
because you will
you will detect the the rna assuming
that you perform as i mentioned you
perform
an optimal procedure and uh
and if you test beyond the day
uh six or day five you most likely to
see
a lot of uh false negative if you run
the pcr
compared to the to the immune
when we look at the immune detection
uh tests it will be also
highly uh will yield high false negative
at the beginning of the symptoms because
there is no immunity
but it will be highly sensitive and
highly uh
sensitivity and like beyond the day six
so let's talk about uh so
because based on this criteria
and the difference between the two tests
the performance of the two
those two tests cdc announced
uh the surveillance of u.s serology
testing strategy with this
uh the the objectives of this strategy
is to provide
more complete estimate on how common the
vir
the virus or the disease is
and to guide the measure
the control measures such as social
distancing can be opening
the questions cdcr is trying to to
answer
using this method or this strategy is
that how much
of the earth's population have been
infected without showing symptoms
and how much of this population have
been affected generally
and if there if these antibodies or this
immune immunity
can be associated with the protection
and uh
from future re-infection and if they
have any therapeutic implications
so let's describe the the current
methods of
serology testing so
uh the majority of
these tests are based on the lateral
flow uh say
uh techniques which is
uh described in this uh slide so
basically this is the card
that is uh simply you load the sample on
this card and then
you load the buffer the samples will
flow laterally
through the through different phases the
the
the first phase is attached it contains
uh gold carbon-19 antigen conjugates
and once these antigen conjugates
encounter
anti-covalent 19 antibody in the sample
it will show this light uh red
line on the on the step 5
and then you also have a control
which is a rabbit gold conjugate a
control
indicator so as the sample
goes forward to the second line which is
c here
it should light up to show that the
control is positive so you know that
the test is valid so in in step 7
you see that the positive test is should
contain
the line for t the test and line for c
the control
and the negative test should contain
only the line of c that is the test is
valid but
no line for t
and if the if there's no c line the
control line then the test is not
valid anymore so um
there are so far there are
like uh tens of approved uh fda
uh serology tests i'm just showing a
couple of them now
um they are different uh
there are different vendors they're
different manufacturers
uh abbott celix abbott and silix are the
most commonly used but you see here they
have
different performance from sensitivity
of 100
and uh 93 percent even though they are
measuring the same target the igg for
nuclear capsid
or the igg4 spike one thing
here is that i i didn't show uh showed
here in this slide
um the majority of these tests have
validated
validated this um performance
after day 12 of the onset of symptoms
and some of them
uh showed these uh figures of
sensitivity and specificity
after day 14. so
now let's talk about the rational or the
basics of our luminex beat based
tests so our test is based on the
platform uh invented by luminex xmap
based technology basically this is this
technology is based on the
reaction uh or creating the antigen or
the target
on the paramagnetic microsphere
or beads these beads are internally
uh dyed with two colors the infrared and
red
fluorophores these two colors would give
the beads they are in different
proportions so
they give those beads different uh
a color region or different id that can
be detected
and can be distinguished from the other
beads so you
can you have more than
500 bead regions
and you can just you can easily
distinguish
between those beads based on the color
so uh in order to develop this essay
basically uh you have the bead
and and you
can using the carbamide uh based
reaction you conjugate the
the protein or the target or the
capture molecule on the bead
and then you expose this uh
sorry you expose this the uh b
to the to the sample serum plasma
urine or any kind of liquid biopsy
sample
and then you add the secondary reporter
that is conjugated with biotin
and then finally you you add the
fluorophore
so there are different formats of this
uh of this
essay components or this uh assay uh
this one specifically i'm in this one
i'm describing what we do
what we did for this test this is called
indirect assay
for antibodies as well when you
conjugate the antigen
on the bead in order to detect the
antibody and the serum
the other formats are
are if you play with the arrangement of
this
essay you actually conjugate if and if
you you actually conjugate the ante
body on the beats you can detect the
cytokines or the protein
that is soluble in the in the
biospecimen
with that we we we call it uh capture
assay for cytokines it could be
cytokines hormones
soluble receptors lichens any any form
of protein that is soluble
the third uh form of this assay would be
specifically for the for the nuclear
nucleic acid
is when you have uh tag and anti-tag uh
react to each other and report it with
the fluorophore
finally these beads uh
will be these bits will be
uh mixed to it with with each other i
mean imagine you
you're performing a a multiplexed essay
where you take in each of these bead
regions
uh and conjugate it to a specific
uh target let's say
you have a bead one for il-6
and b2 for tgf beta
now when you when you mix them together
and you can as i said you can mix up to
500 beats and now even more
according to the next generation
instruments developed by luminix
now if you in the in the luminex
instrument you expose these beats into
two forms of laser beams
the green one is to detect the target
the red one is to detect
the bead region that's why the the
multiplexing
capability of the instrument uh so
if you if the the
the beads the the beads will flow by
uh via a stream like in in a streamline
like the flow cytometry
technique and the both lights will be
able to
detect the beat number or the beat id
and the associated or the conjugated
target the amount of target as
conjugated to these speeds uh one thing
to mention that
for illustrative purposes i draw one
molecule here but you can imagine on the
surface of these beads you can conjugate
as
many as millions of of uh of molecules
so you can detect
millions of uh of uh of target molecules
on the surface of these beads that's why
it's considered highly sensitive
compared to conventional methods like
elisa um
one thing also to mention one of the uh
advantages of this is the is being
uh immobilizing the
immobilizing the target on those freely
mobile
beads it allows more interaction with
the sample with targets on the sample
that's why
you see also high sensitivity of the
results
so to in order to design this essay you
have to go through different
different phases so first you have to
uh you have to identify your targets and
this is usually based on
different methods so either you go based
on the bioinformatics
uh analysis of current currently
available data to identify your targets
that you're gonna be testing for
second is or the second option is to go
based on the knowledge of the
pathological pathways or the pathways
responsible for the diseases and you
select your
molecules of interest a third way is to
uh
to follow the analytical proteomics
approach like mass spectrometry and
basic uh proteomics approach to identify
your potential candidate target and then
you
design this assay second you
you purchase the reagents and this is
not easy process actually
you have to you have to figure out which
the the best reagents that you can
uh implement in this test
and you have to validate them to make
sure that they work too together
then you go the third step is the
coupling reaction to couple those
uh capture molecules on the microspheres
and then finally you optimize the assay
into
in terms of uh sa performance specifics
like the linearity the dynamic range and
cross reactivity and so on so this is
the
the form of our s of our assay
in
so we have uh four beat regions we
uh conjugated uh those four main
components of the
you know uh coronavirus on each beat
so uh we designated one beat for the
spike
and nuclear capsid and uh for the other
be the for the nuclear capsid
and uh and so on so we have four uh
uh unique bead regions for uh one for
each
uh spike sorry one for each antigen
and we multiplexed them together and we
optimized the assay
according to the white box that you see
on the left
so we optimized all these uh specifics
the linearity detection limits
uh sensitivity precision cluster
activity and
and so on we validated the test
on the uh two groups uh
the coveted uh positive group and the
control group
and then we read them on the luminix
forum
and uh i will report the results uh
later
uh so this is just a description of the
of the essay these are indirect immunity
assays
uh it contains the spike nucleocapsid
metrics and uh and the envelope proteins
or protein
uh targets sorry to capture those
antibodies specific for those
uh they have uh we are looking for
uh uh to
forward to improve this performance but
we already tested the
igg iga igm and also the total
igm so to start with uh as i mentioned
before i
have some limitation to uh or
restriction to declare
much of data here but here i am showing
an example of the sa range and the
linearity of the spike and the nuclear
capsule for example
we go into since that we were able to
get sensitivity as
low as uh decimals of picograms
per ml and uh
we again uh one of the advantages that i
didn't mention
uh is the of this test is that we
capture the four of them
at once so you even if you missed the
even if the patient did not develop the
the antibody for spike you're not going
to miss it if he
if the patient developed antibodies for
for
nuclear capsid we still can test it
positive based on the algorithm that we
developed later
so the first validation we did is to
accommodate the
the the the method of
specimen collection which is based on
the drive.spot
basically this these cards are available
for low costs and it can be
shipped at home like shipped to to the
patient house and we can
perform the fingerprint test and just
send it back
by usbs
here we show in the the difference so
let me talk about these figures
these are actually the first validation
group is that
it's the 10 positive cases and 10
control cases and you can see the
difference in the
in the level of the mfi
you can clearly distinguish the positive
from negative by the difference in the
uh at the level of the average mfi
um here in the in the
light blue color or the turquoise color
it's the spike plasma
concentration uh spike antibody
and the light one was the one that it's
uh
measured from the dry blood spot so you
see it's it's
it followed the same strange that's why
i'm showing this line
graph is to show that they follow the
same
pattern but with a little bit lower uh
intensity of the mfi this can be
optimized
but what we're trying to show here is
that the the
the feasibility or the applicability of
dry blood
spot to collect sample for this test
the second uh the second
validation we try to test is the is the
accommodation of
the 38 uh four-wheel plates
uh in layout of uh uh
96 well plates so 96 will play it's
uh these are the this is how we
performed this test so far
uh uh the all this the
all the steps that we performed were on
96 well plates
with 96 volt plates you can perform uh
40 samples per plate
but with 384 you can uh tests for
184 samples per plate so that's with
that we
try to show that we can accommodate this
platform or this uh plaid format
or in order to accommodate more testing
uh
capacity for for this platform
and here in the figure again you show
you see the the turquoise color is the
is based on the 96 well plates
and the the the intensity of the mfi
went a little bit down but uh it still
followed the same
the same uh uh pattern when we tested
the
the the samples on the 384 uh
plates so again it's when you
accommodate this this you need to
optimize it
but it's still showing the same
reasons the same sensitivity and the
specificity
performance and
then we also validated the
the timing so we considered that shorter
time will be helpful to
uh to uh to
to to unload this test to be
more uh feasible in this
pandemic strategy so the regular time
for the test
is uh is eight hours total but in order
to
to uh scale it down to a couple of hours
we we showed that first we can we can
optimize the secondary antibody
uh now we we showed how can we optimize
the
the primary antibody incubation from
four hours to half
to half an hour you see here the white
color is for four hours inhibition and
the the light blue color is for the
30 minutes incubation of course there is
a
the there's a decrease in this intensity
of the mfi
but um it still shows the same
pattern or the same uh sensitivity to
distinguish the copper 19 positive from
the country
and with that we can we can scale down
the performance time of this essay to
the half
that's four hours or three hours we also
did the same thing with the secondary so
we
we we tested the one hour incubation
versus
30 minutes incubation and again it
showed not that much different of the
of the in terms of the mfi signal
so we still can accommodate this
this time too so the total test will be
around four hours or three hours
[Music]
finally we did the validation uh
with uh with the clinical samples from
uh
with the clinical samples from larger
cohort so we did
we first selected the the control cohort
uh around 262 cases
from the collected during the
speak of flu season the sorry the peak
flu season that's collected
from november to march last year
in our biorepository uh with that we we
aim to
make sure that this does not this this
does not cross react or give false
positive
with other flu like viruses
about 75 percent of those
cases where copd that's chronic uh
obstructive pulmonary diseases cases in
this cohort
and they did not test positive uh with
uh
with pcr for coven 19.
the positive cohort was 180 samples
collected
at rush university medical center from
march 1st to april 10th
and they all tested positive and they
showed symptoms
of coronavirus of carbon
and uh just one thing to mention about
the
the the drawback of this cohort is that
it has been collected uh regardless the
time the onset of symptoms so we break
down the
the the those cases according to the
time when
where when their samples were collected
so
182 188 128 sorry samples were collected
in the first two days
and i put this figure again to remind
you that
during those first three days you expect
to sell
to to see low sensitivity of the
serum test of the antibody test so
as we expected when we run the test
for the boss control and positive group
we saw loss sensitivity and
but i just have to mention here that we
do
when we're on the test we developed uh
that classification algorithm
on the uh our part using our part
package on
our program to come up with a
classification
algorithm to help using those four
targets to to classify the patients or
to predict
the diagnosis so here's the performance
the sensitivity in overall results
regardless the time
of pcr tested test
the sensitivity was 55 percent the
specificity was 98
and accuracy was eighty percent
and uh uh
and the the negative predictor here was
79
uh 76 now we optimized this
cohort to include only
people who were tested three days
and beyond three days and beyond the
onset of symptoms
so we have we applied the same algorithm
the same classification algorithm and
we we come up with better
or improvement of this performance of
the sensitivity and specificity so
the sensitivity was 92 percent
specificity was 98
and accuracy was 97
then we went further to include
only six days and beyond
and i want to remind you that
the majority of the tests are under
according to the fda
sorry i didn't mention this but
according to the fda recommendation is
to test
uh to validate these tests is to test
beyond
day 12 of the onset and now we are
trying the
day six and beyond and implemented the
same
uh uh classification
classification algorithm that we
developed
and we ended up with sensitivity of 100
percent
specificity of 98 percent and the
accuracy of 98
now we went to the second phase of the
validation when we increased
the control group to close to 1 000
patients
and with that we aim to use
according to the recommendation from
from fda
is to use uh as much large cohort as
possible for from the control to make
sure that this test is applicable
on the as a screening test
and the control group uh contains four
four patients collected to uh
in uh 12 days so with that we
we redesigned the classification
algorithm
uh using our program to
to show this to end up with this
classification
system so let me describe this
classification
algorithm briefly so you start when you
have the sample you
you look the algorithm will be
automatically run to first look at the
spike antibody
if it's more than 40 picograms per ml
it will go automatically to look at the
nuclear capsid antibody
if it is more than 24 picograms then the
patient is posit positive if it's less
than
24 picograms and also less than 40
picograms of
of spike the the blue colored is
uh then you look at the membrane
antibody
if it is negative that is uh less than
one microgram per ml then the patient is
negative
if it is more than one microgram per
parameter
you look at the envelope uh antibody
if the envelope antibody is uh more than
28
micrograms if the case is positive
and if it's less than that the case is
negative so
in this just one thing to mention that
this is all
is uh bioinformatics system so you just
you basically
run the raw data on the bioinformatics
program and it will come up with this
decision either positive or negative
so when we did this test on the 100
uh 1178
patients we came up with uh with
sensitivity of 100
specificity of 9.6
and accuracy of 99.6 percent
that is that is uh uh
as uh is outstanding performance
comparing to other
tests and also we are
pro we are presenting uh
a method a multiplex method to test four
uh targets at once our four antibodies
at once so you make sure you do not miss
this case even if the patient did not
develop
uh antibody for one of them
uh so again these are the the
performance of the other uh of the
current tests which is uh comparable to
others
uh now when we talk about the how can we
implement this test
generally if you wanna incorporate it
with the pcr testing
in in order to diagnose or plan the
uh for uh for back to to work or
reopening
so simply if you have if you conduct
uh if you have negative pcr test that
there's that means there's no indication
of the virus
in the body and if you have also a
negative antibody test that means you
are
you have you haven't encountered this
virus before and you are susceptible so
you
the decision that can be taken based on
that is to maintain social distancing
and stay home
if the pcr was was positive
and the antibody was negative that means
you are infected but you don't have
immunity yet
you're supposed to go into quarantine
you are infectious
simply if the both this were positive
you are also um in infectious phase
uh uh and you uh and you you you are you
are and
you you have the virus and you have the
immunity so you are
still in you need you need to be in
quarantine because you're still uh in a
fiction space however when when the
immunes
when the immune test is positive and
pcr is negative that means you
the patient has encountered the the
virus at some point
in the past and then he developed
immunity
this will make him or make the that
person categorized or that we can
categorize this person as a safe person
and he can go back to work go back to
school
and without being concerned to
infect or spread infection to other
people
so the immediate application of this
test
is to provide a convenient and
cost-effective
means to test non-vulnerable populations
or non-symptomatic populations
mainly those groups that i mentioned
before
the 66 percent uh young and middle-aged
groups
who are we expect that those are dynamic
uh
portion of the population they go to
schools they go to work
they hang out all the time you can you
can
you can prove you can screen those
people
in large scale and decide and help to
plan
to return to work or stay home decisions
uh we with this test we investing that
we provide means to
evaluate plasma in the blood banks for
therapeutic
conventional therapeutic plasma
uh to use based on the strength of
immunoreceptor of immune response sorry
um to the covet 19 covenanting virus
and we also can use this test as a
companion diagnostics method for
uh to monitor the vaccine efficacy and
duration of
antibody titers it can be also
be convenient to epidemiological
monitoring of infection rates worldwide
and as i mentioned before the
according to uh across the regions of
the
countries or the states uh it also will
relieve the burden of the clinical
laboratories struggling to keep up with
the pcr based tests
of active cases the the backlog of these
tests
now usually they run them in three days
or two days
um the future directives is uh
regarding this test is that we're gonna
uh refine the essay
and uh transform it to automate
automated workflow and again we're going
to accommodate 384 well plates
and optimize it further for uh
dry blood spot method
and we also we are collecting we are
actively collecting more
samples uh uh from uh rush
university medical center to uh
prepare for fda uh validation in the
next two weeks
using the the emergency use
authorization
we have multiple federal funding
mechanisms
being pursued for chicago-based research
networking and we are open for
uh collaborate collaborators
uh this is like i mentioned we currently
we the russia is in going
uh is is doing an ongoing collection of
samples and admitting patients
and testing screening patients in the
community
uh in chicago so we are uh also taking
samples
uh in our buyer facility to
to further validate this test to
conclude the slides i wish
every everyone uh to stay home and
practice social distancing
and uh hop if you have any question
please ask me
now uh in the qa session or you can
you can contact dr jeffrey borgia on his
email showing on the slide
if you have any additional question or
interest to
collaborate and research or license
agreement
thank you so much susie
and thank you dr jarone for your
informative presentation
and we will now start the q and a
portion of the webinar
so if you have any questions you'd like
to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so dr shawnee we
already have
several questions coming in from our
audience members
and thank you all for joining us today
what's the plasma sample
dilution in the slide shown
so we did the one to 500 delusions we
we tested multiple dilutions but
currently we uh
we identified one to 500 as the best
thank you for that and the sensitivity
is low 55
when samples within the first three days
on symptom
onset and much better starting from six
days
how early can we consider this test with
acceptable accuracy
so like i showed
we can we expect accuracy
comparable to current tests at day six
so which is still an outstanding
performance because a lot of these
figures that we saw from other tests are
tested at
day 12 and beyond and we were able to
show the same figure at basics
thank you and are there any other
serological tests
which only detect one target but have
the same
the clinical validation performance as
yours and if there were
why could they achieve it without using
your multi-testing strategy
um can can you say that that question
again
sure of course are there are there any
other
serological tests which could only
detect one target
but have the same clinical validation
performance as yours
uh there are actually what i showed the
current tests
available they all have the same
the majority of them have the same
characteristics but this is
according to their validation studies
and uh what i'm trying to mention here
is i'm not i'm not like criticizing
anybody but
a lot of these this when when they were
tested and from other institutions
they they showed different uh different
characteristics
different performance and um
yeah so there's a lot of debates there
are a lot of debates
on the the actual performance of these
tests
uh but they are still like uh
outperforming tests that's that's how
can i say
thank you for that we have time for a
few more questions
can you collect plasma from a patient
who still has
positive results for the virus
yes of course is that the plasma for
diagnostic purposes or for the
therapeutic purposes
perhaps they can rewrite they'll have to
rewrite they're in the question and we
can answer that on
in a maybe written and why do you choose
a cohort of age median of over 60 for
your clinical validation
so those are so first this is the cohort
in our by ambassador
um second these are the most vulnerable
group
uh for the cover 19 tests
and i mean as i mentioned uh
majority of these tests are majority of
these this at russia university
were conducted on the um those patients
were admitted in russian
so these have uh uh
you know
those are the majority of them are in
this age group
speaking of the the control group these
are the
the patients that we screened for lung
cancer
previously and they have this average of
this age of average of asia
thank you very much and what is the
dilution with
dried blood spot
um so i i'm okay
uh the dilution we're still optimizing
it but
that dilution that we did um at that
time was uh
one two one uh one to five hundred as
well
we're testing different dilutions as of
today
we're testing another dilutions for uh
for a dry blood spot
thank you and again audience members
great questions coming in
any questions we can't answer today will
be answered via email
and dr sterling is your test qualitative
or
quantitative can be both it's uh where
we run now is
a quantitative test with a standard
curve
and we can perform it on a qualitative
basis
as a positive negative thank you and
our final question how did you validate
the quantitative part of your algorithm
do you have controls for this and if so
what are they
yeah that's why this is the the initial
quantitative
test was based on the two things so
first was the
the recombinant proteins and the
antibodies from other species we also
used
standard curve from serial diluted
samples
now and for being positive but of course
we're now
developing uh we're now pursuing uh
actual purification of the human
antibodies to
run the quantity quantitative uh
standard curve
we're looking for these uh yeah
dr tony thank you for your presentation
today do you have any final
closing remarks that you'd like to say
to the audience before we close today
um no actually just uh i wanna
stress on the advantage of multiplexing
uh
strategy when you develop tests versus
using
versus using a uniplex or one target
we've been known for as a group to
develop the multiplexing
tests for screening of lung cancer and
prognos developing prognostic tests for
lancaster and we encountered that
we we experienced the difference between
looking at
one target at time versus looking at
different
uh biomarkers at once it's more
informative
more accurate more sensitive and more uh
it
outperforms other platforms
dr tony thank you for your presentation
and for your time today
and your important research and before
we go i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
i'd also like to thank our sponsor
luminex for the sponsoring today's
webinar
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
through the end
of 2020. labrets will alert you via
email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time stay safe
take care and bye bye
thank you thank you so much